being 10 o'clock I'm going to open the
uh subcommittee work session on House
Bill 109.
um it's my understanding this is live
stream so we're going to use the
microphones and I'm sitting here
um
because you know Center for that
so
as I see it there's a couple of
different amendments being proposed
Carol McGuire
um proposed one that we can talk about
and uh
oplc brought one and I mean does anybody
just initial thoughts on this before we
go get going further or
Carol's not here it's her
her bill so if there's nothing I mean as
uh
as I read it and people can yes
turn your mic on
thank you Mr chair I was hoping that we
could just give a a quick overview I
don't have the original bill in front of
me okay and I don't have any extra
copies sorry
um or you can come over here and look at
it with me but
okay
so it reenacts it repeals and reenacts
RSA 3206 C1 which is the occupational
therapists the definitions
and um
actually Lindsay if you could come up
and talk about
the changes in the bill that you're
aware of and then
um
this amendment you're proposing might be
helpful to give an overview and then
talk about your Amendment sure thank you
Mr Chair by the record Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc
um I would actually rely on the
association to speak in Greater detail
about the changes my understanding when
talking to members in the practice is
that essentially they were just intended
to tighten up the definitions and the
scope of practice for OTS that there are
many substantive changes
representative McGuire's Amendment
ads language to include
Leisure Leisure social activity and the
like as within the definition of
Occupational Therapy Services what our
proposed amendment would do is to make
clear that
um that individuals licensed under other
license types who are permitted to
perform similar services
are permitted to continue to do so
specifically recreational therapy we
were concerned that without the
additional language that the ACT could
be construed to require Rec therapists
to also seek licensure as occupational
therapists which are obviously two
distinct professions so that's why we
proposed that change
okay thank you um so if the folks from
the association come up and uh
oh yep there you go thank you Mr chair
I'm Denise Finch occupational therapist
in New Hampshire also a member of the
legislative committee for the New
Hampshire tea Association
uh I'm Daniel Wise from Concord and I'm
a certified occupational therapy
assistant and also on the uh from the
association's uh committee that working
for the language that
representative McGuire put in the
addendum that was just an inadvertent
exclusion initially that language has
always been part of the OT Practice Act
it was just left out inadvertently so
social participation play and Leisure is
not new it's just needs to be there it
used to be there so that's our focus on
that the oplc member Amendment we have
we are in support of because it's
consistent with other Allied Health
practice acts and protects all of the
practice acts as well as the public
thank you
um so if you could give your view on the
the overall Bill let's say with both of
those amendments if we were to do that
oh well we um we support the this this
bill we helped uh
um we helped to draft it it was
basically uh an update uh of The
Practice Act statute had for
occupational therapy had not been
updated since uh for about 14 years 14
or 15 years and uh well what we do has
not changed
um the way we do it and the way it was
described was was really out of date and
we looked to language that um our
National Association has developed in
other states to sort of harmonize our
practice with others so it it doesn't
really expand any um expand what we do
uh the only thing that uh sort of
change that it did make was it removed
some language
um Antiquated language about requiring a
referral
for certain
um
certain therapy certain uses of
Occupational Therapy from a physician
which uh is something that is of concern
in this Medicaid in schools program
um and there that kids are they go
through special ed very regulated
process and occupational therapy is
included in in what they do and then the
schools were required to go through this
unnecessary step of getting some doctor
to sign his name to the referral even
though the doctor was not necessarily
involved
in the assessment at all
and so that language was removed and
um
there's a lot of support for that as
well from the school uh special
education administrations
um which wrote in support of the bill
also
okay thank you
um this questions uh Peter
um thank you Mr chair so uh do you have
a fair amount of experience under the
old regime if you will where doctors
were required to get involved
uh actually that's kind of a little
above my pay grade
um as an assistant uh I did therapy in
schools uh uh myself
um but
um that was something that others in the
association uh who were familiar with
the school process
um well what I'm what I'm getting at is
that that you've already testified to
the fact that
um it's an unnecessary action and very
often involving somebody who doesn't
know
as much about it as the practitioners do
uh but but to the degree that that this
person would be a gatekeeper
uh and his or her involvement would be
required now you've got to find somebody
that's willing to sit there and sign off
because to the agree that they're
signing their name they're going to want
to have some level of of ability to say
no otherwise they're just a rubber stamp
and and and very often people who are
highly qualified in a profession don't
like the idea that they're signing their
name to something that they really don't
understand
um and so finding somebody that's
willing to do that is can be very
difficult and if you don't if you don't
have them it's kind of like in your note
from your mother you don't have it the
teacher says you're staying after class
or something like that so it's just a
constriction or restriction that serves
no purpose uh so I'm just wondering if
you if either one of you has any
experience at how much of a of a noose
and a roadblock a bottleneck this has
been in under the old system
well we know from our peers that are
working in the settings that
a tremendous burden for school systems
it limits and slows access to services
for students so we're very concerned
about that
speech therapy and PT our Allied Health
profession Partners do not have this
restriction because they long ago
remove that requirement in their
practice act so we're really looking to
improve access to clients students but
also in the community so my background
is working as a private practitioner
with people with disabilities trying to
help them get back to work
and the limitation for me if I worked in
a work setting would be that I would
have to go find a physician to re
request my services I could be just
going in to do an ergonomic assessment
to you know improve the setup or making
an adaptation and so it's additional
expense into the system system
delay on the part of the client and then
you know delay on the provision of
services so
in the current status you know state of
health care you want to try to we want
to try to follow these leads of reducing
cost improving access making
clients have more control over you know
what they can get for services and where
and how quickly
right and the delay aspect of course is
one of the things I'm chiefly concerned
with because if you've got somebody
who's I know suffering basically uh and
and and they they're having to sit and
wait
like sitting at a traffic light that
just doesn't change after a while you
start to steam starts coming out of your
ear so I I am very supportive of getting
rid of that representative Barry you had
a question
of microphone yeah
it's Friday I'm feeling a little bit
more relaxed
my question is what was the compelling
reason for coming here today what why
Dan wasn't even a first time
um you mean for the bill itself or for
today
um well the the
um
the access uh part the removing the
referral part was was a part of it but
the overall reason I mean the reason it
wasn't what we started with it was
basically the fact that this did need to
be updated was
um a big part of it it was just nodding
it not in concert with what
um existed elsewhere in terms of
language the language was just really
antiquated
so um anyone else
um have any questions okay all right
thank you
um
so director Courtney do you have any
thank you Mr chair the agency isn't
taking a position on the bill one way or
the other
um but uh would ask that if the bill
does move forward that the language
we've proposed be
um added just to make clear that we're
not requiring other licensed
professionals to obtain an OT license
okay thank you anyone else here who'd
like to speak on HB 109
okay I mean what I would you know in any
discussion that people have yep
representative
thank you Mr chair I think that both
amendments are
um warranted to the bill and I would
suggest that we add the oplc language to
the amendment that representative
McGuire submitted and we submit we
present one Amendment to the committee
for this bill yeah that was my uh my
thought as well um well somebody else
wants to do it I can I can send this to
oplc and get that movie unless somebody
else is happy to do it
hola sorry I'll be glad to pop down
there after this meeting and take care
of it right away yeah get them to do a
new Amendment with both pieces correct
wonderful thank you you're welcome any
any if there's any other discussion
okay so uh to be official I'll take uh
you know for the voting members uh which
I think with Replacements everybody here
but Peter
um so the motion is to adopt the
amendment that representative Grotto
will have drafted that will combine
um representative McGuire's Amendment
and the proposed amendment from oplc
um
well I I talked with Carol about this
and she said that
we can do this as the intent of the
committee the right now we you know it's
a full committee is going to have to
adopt the the amendment so this isn't
if we vote separately on the two
amendments sure then we put them
together and present that to the full
committee yeah I'd be glad to do that
um
all right so
first
I mean I'll make the motion um to adopt
Amendment
um
2023-0030h which was uh the chair
McGuire's amendment is any discussion on
that one
okay
um so representative groda
I second
you second ah thank you for catching me
on that thank you very much
um
all right
okay thank you
and
um representative
I vote Yes representative Bear yes and I
uh the chair votes yes
okay we will take the amendment which I
think
we'll take the proposed amendment
um uh that was presented by oplc and I
think you all have a copy of it
and I will move adopting
um
having this added to the other Amendment
so any discussion and was there a second
for that I'll second that but let's also
note that when we do that Amendment 0030
will change number
I understand okay and I'll put you and I
as the sponsors of that Amendment that's
fine okay yeah I know they're
they don't change existing amendments
they always create a new one so yep
all right um any discussion on this one
no all right
um representative groda
aye representative schuette yes
representative a bear yes and the chair
votes yes and I think we're done with uh
House Bill 109 and we have a
just so you can hear I I have a
um
and a bill of my own being heard in
state and federal I think at 11 15 and I
have to make sure that my amendment is
in in hand for the Committees so I will
absent myself shortly but but I'll stay
as long as I can okay thank you and do
foreign
um I'm going to open the subcommittee
work session on House Bill
and
this is addressing a notice
and as I recall
there were a couple issues there was um
I think I don't know if it's actually
have to look here and see if it was a
formal Amendment
um it's not actually an official
Amendment but the sponsor said they made
a mistake concerning what part of
Statute they put it into
and that that as I recall resulted in
proposed amendment you know pass around
right
um
and because it was the wrong place it it
you know various things I guess had to
be reviewed by lawyers because it was in
the hearing part of it so there's that
issue and I guess there were issues
about the need for information becoming
public potential need to redact it and
then there's some other discussions but
um uh direct recording if you uh come up
and
please give your view on the situation
thank you Mr chair for the record
Lindsay Courtney executive director
office of professional ice Insurance
certification
the agency isn't taking a bill on or
taking a position on this bill
um but we but we do recognize that
there's a lot of stakeholder interest in
ensuring that our operations are
transparent which we fully support we
had some concern around the original
language that it wouldn't give us enough
flexibility or the boards enough
flexibility to add items to board
agendas that were of an urgent nature
but not an emergency under RSA 91 a we
also had some concerns as you recall
about having to review every
um every piece of information or every
piece of materials prior to disclosure
specifically applications that may be
reviewed in public but
contain sensitive information that's
confidential so anyways I worked with
representative Merchant and we came to a
agreement that would address my concerns
it would also address the issue with the
improper placement and that's what he
circulated I think yesterday to the
committee and essentially what it does
is it still requires the office to
provide the public notice of a public
meeting no less than 14 days prior to
the meeting
it requires the board through the office
to
provide or make available all of the
information distributed to the board
unless the the materials contain
information
exempt from disclosure under 91a so that
would satisfy Our concern with having to
um spend a lot of time redacting
applications
it also allows the chair of the board to
add agenda items within those seven days
um
basically if in their discretion it's
it's necessary to do so to satisfy
public interest and then it provides for
a basis for us to provide those
materials to the public
so again we don't take a position on it
but I think it you know I think
certainly it'll address the physical
concerns as well
um and I think it's a good
um
anyways it's a good compromise I think
okay
um thank you so um you spoke with
representative Martian uh Prime sponsor
he's happy with with this yes correct
okay I've got a
couple questions one one concern about
[Music]
um
see where's the part here about uh
not making materials available
if they have private information
so I just got this
are you talking about that the 91a yep
it says all materials distributed to the
board for the meeting shall be available
to the public no less than seven days
prior to the meeting yeah my question on
that my concern is
[Music]
um
you know I don't know what these
materials look like and I'm wondering if
you know a large portion of them have
some private information on them along
with information that really the public
should have access to and whether
putting this exception in
rather than you know the redacting
process is going to
cover
most of the material or only you know
it's a material to private information
tend to be
you know Limited in at least the
documents that contain it
yeah I think that's a legitimate a
concern I would say
most documents reviewed in public
session do not contain personal
information or information confidential
under 91a the
um the type of materials that I'm
talking about are licensure applications
which are public documents and can be
released but we have to redact you know
their social security number which is
required and their personal email
address and all of that stuff and when
talking to representative Merchant and
some of the other stakeholders they said
they really weren't interested in those
types of documents and it would
significantly reduce the cost of having
us review applications to redact the
materials if we could just exempt that
those type of materials
okay and you said they're they're public
documents so today what would they be
released under 91a and then you do the
redacting at that point yes we do do
that yep okay
um anybody any comp questions or from
um
you know representative Grotto went off
okay uh representative bear
hey there sorry Mr chair if
I'm brand new with this so if I if I uh
don't don't just go on okay
um so I did have a constituent come to
me and I did reach out to
um director Courtney
regarding adding to the agenda the
language of
director director Courtney I don't know
if you remember exactly the exact
language yes that has come up within 48
Hours something to that effect yes I can
look that up I don't know whether it's
too late to add that or whether that
would is within the 91a
is are you concerned about uh but you
want them to have the ability to add
things
um
at the last minute if they feel
necessary in that language I believe is
in here
says the chair of the board counselor
commission shall be permitted to add a
gen items to the agenda within seven
days by meeting if in the chair's
discretion The public's interest in the
board addressing the matter outweighs
the Public's interest in timely access
to materials associated with the new
agenda item
just kind of in the middle we don't know
why numbers but what line is that Mr
chair with their own online number this
is this is a document I handed out
the draft the draft legislation
yeah I mean
I kind of have a concern about that
although I understand the reason for it
it's certainly something that could be
abused I would hope it would not be
I suppose if we hear about it a lot of
problems with being abused we could
certainly I'm I'm thinking that
um where representative Merchant who was
a board member brought this whole issue
to us that if issues such as that come
up they will certainly be brought before
that I imagine so thank you and
representative grow to anything on this
this is the notice
um
we're going to be um if you're referring
to the amendment that oplc submitted
correct yes no I have no questions okay
um is there anybody else uh present
who'd like and thank you anybody else
here president who wants to speak on uh
good morning representative and thank
you for
um letting me speak for a few minutes I
think to representative a bear's
comments I think where I represent the
electrical contractors and I believe one
of it and what what's your name yes oh
sorry Simon Thompson with no
p-t-h-o-m-s-o-n I represent the ecba
electrical contractors Business
Association and I'm not going to go
through a list I also have several other
clients who are um just the ones that
yeah no so
um
I think just seeing uh director
Courtney's language
we number one we're wanting to know when
the meetings are 14 days in advance and
that's what this does we wanted to have
the material that's going to be
discussed as soon as possible that says
seven days the language about you know
kind of high priority sensitive matters
that need to be dealt with in a timely
manner we understand that a good example
is Massachusetts reciprocal issue came
to the attention of the electrician's
board like literally the day of before
the meeting and it was a big hot button
issue so yeah we want to talk about that
in a timely manner I haven't heard
directly back from my client having just
seen this I would just say at this point
what makes me feel pretty comfortable is
that it says uh in the chairs discretion
the chair of that board if if he or she
feels that we need to deal with this
then I think we feel pretty comfortable
with it I'd like to review it maybe
discuss it if we do have major concerns
if the full committee's executive
session but I just wanted to weigh in
that I think this this accomplishes a
lot like what we'd like to see okay I
mean I I suspect that the full committee
I don't know that uh the chair or the
full committee would be having people
comment it might it's possible but right
but I mean I'm just trying to get that
we could we could weigh in but I mean
it's also this just came here and
nobody's seen it so we could weigh in
like via email right yeah I was going to
suggest that if you have concerns uh
please email the full committee
absolutely okay uh and and I'll talk to
you about the next bill uh as well
all right thank you
oh uh representative bear
thank you
um thank you for being here this morning
I believe my constituent is one of your
clients and I've been communicating with
him as well as communicating with
director Courtney and I'll keep him
informed and if you want to share your I
just sent it to him so he's probably
wiring something right now
thank you thank you and thank you any
other questions no thank you thank you
um anybody else who wants to speak on
House Bill 337 no okay
any comments or discussions for members
I think
sounding as though everyone is pretty
comfortable with the amended proposal
if you would like I can have it drafted
as an official amendment that we can
okay so you can make a motion make a
motion to adopt this proposed amendment
and um
any discussion I'm guessing no
all right representative groda
yes
representative
yes representative a bearer yes and the
chair votes yes
and uh we've got about 15 minutes until
the next one actually we have more than
that
foreign
take their seats
I'm gonna open the subcommittee work
session on House Bill
258.
um
and
just a little you know my take on what's
been going on in it and you know
actually
representative Kelly or someone correct
me and that is the original bill
um
it came out of Olas nothing like what
the prime sponsor wanted and because of
the ols's under the problems they've had
and delays there was no chance to
redraft it so that's
my understanding of what happened there
and um
and there was an amendment to try and
deal with that which
the discussions we had at the committee
seem to indicate uh here it is
there were that that was not
accomplishing what the prime sponsor
wanted either and you can speak Diane if
you want to come up
Diane
do you want to come up for a moment
representative Kelly
sorry should be official
I've known you too much too well so I
tell you do that
um so
uh you know it it's corrected the
original Bill wasn't what you wanted and
is it also true that the amendment is
not necessarily doing what you'd prefer
I'm kind of okay with my Amendment okay
um but I realize that there are people
who are not and I am willing to discuss
ways to make everybody happy and
actually I'm trying to find your
Amendment
okay actually here's why that's why I'm
not finding it
no no no no
okay
I know I've got it here
[Music]
um
do you have the um do you have the
amendment I have her um Amendment this
is uh zero zero five one eight yeah
um and
as I recall there was concern that
um
I mean what this does is it says the
practice of veterinary medicine shall
not include any treatment offered by a
person licensed under RSA 316a which I
um part of the statute
but while that that statute does not
indicate that it's specifically for
humans that was the intent I suppose you
know if alien warthogs came down to
earth they might be uh could be
practiced under there but that's not
what the uh uh you know chiropractors
are trained for and so this really
doesn't have I mean 316a doesn't have
anything to do
with animals and so you know I would
suggest that that this isn't going to do
what was wanted so any comments on that
yeah okay
um
and as I understand the basic concern is
that
there are people practicing animal
Chiropractic the
um get a little history as I understand
the veterinary board believes that they
come under their Authority the language
and the veterinary part of the statute
is Broad enough they may very well be
correct
um
and people practicing animal
Chiropractic right now are um
it's kind of in the gray area they're
not sure if they're legal or not in the
past but not recently there's been some
cease and desist letters we've heard
testimony that that some are reluctant
to expand their practice or advertise
because they're concerned about their
and um
there's an uh amendment that was I asked
uh director Courtney from oplc to put
together
that
says an individual certified to provide
animal Chiropractic Services that's in
the exception section
but an individual certified to provide
animal Chiropractic Services by a board
recognized National certification body
so this would
would have the veterinary board
um
hopefully approve some one or more
National National certification bodies
as acceptable certification for someone
to do animal Chiropractic
and that that would be the extent of any
regulation on the
so representative short
thank you I do have a question regarding
that
um I assume that director Courtney has
been in touch with the veterinary board
and this would obviously take action on
their part to determine as you say
nationally certified
thank you uh representative Mr chair um
Lindsay Courtney executive director oplc
so the veterinary board has reviewed the
initial language attorney Elizabeth
Eaton is here and can speak about the
board's position on the original
language
um I have not reviewed this draft with
them as they have not met obviously our
intent would be to do so but they have
not taken a position on this at that
time at this time
okay is there anyone here
um from the veterinary board or
representing them who could comment on
this on the
thank you honorable committee members
um my name is Elizabeth Eaton I'm here
from oplc on behalf of the board of
veterinary medicine we discussed the
original language of this
um
bill at the recent meeting
their discussion was fairly succinct
they do not want to be in the business
of certifying chiropractors they they
oppose the language of the original bill
I have not as director Courtney said
have not taken this amendment back to
if any questions
that was the original indication that I
had gotten but now we have this new
proposal I would suggest that we should
actually
wait for final action on this until we
get the verification from the board that
they're willing to do that since it's
going to take action on this it's not an
if that's any other comment and do I
just want to make sure that if we have
that comment from the veterinary board
and it's something they don't object to
that it's going to be something that I
just want to make sure that whatever
steps we take today
is going to get us to where
we're going to end up in it with a happy
solution for everyone so if it would be
possible for us to give us to give
everybody a summary of what would happen
if the veterinary board
um
what your position might be
so that we have an idea of what
direction we're heading in
So based on their discussion uh at the
last meeting I I don't know that they
would be entirely opposed to this
amendment here uh it it seems that it
would just be that they'd have to
promulgate some rules uh to recognize
certain certifications
and then
that the problem that they have is what
happens when an animal chiropractor
um
requires discipline
who's doing the discipline who's
sanctioning the animal chiropractor and
that was one of the they don't want to
be doing that right and thank you and
anything else any other questions
um okay so let's just say that we have a
group of Veterinary chiropractors who
have gone through the certain
accreditation program
is that something that the veterinary
board would be willing to
up approve without certification can we
do that without certified I mean yeah I
mean the other option would be in the
exception thing to basically put
language in there that said that animal
chiropractors don't come under the
authority of the veterinary board and
they wouldn't have to worry about them
at all and I'm wondering what their
position might be on that although I
have a guess
based on their discussion it seemed like
they'd be in favor of that really if
it's a it's a
kind of a tough area because this has
been we you know we looked up
um
if this is happening currently in New
Hampshire and it is
um and
the board just seems to not want to
touch it
um but they could change their mind
based on the new language and the
exception I I don't know okay
um would it be possible uh or
representative bear a bear
foreign
is it possible since the representation
of the veterinary board is here and
saying they don't have a problem with
the amendment for us just to move it
forward well it it's not clear I think
um I mean
my Pro I mean I don't know we can have
the discussion but in one option
um
be I mean it's it's going on right now I
have I don't know if people have heard
of reports of there being problems
um one options to make it clearer to
just clarify their position to say that
they they don't come under the authority
of the veterinary board and let things
continue as they are
um which I'd be okay with I don't know
I
do not feel comfortable giving a
specific answer but I would be happy to
take that back okay um the other thing
is if we schedule a and if we let this
wait and schedule another subcommittee
hearing it'll be good if
I know I don't know if there's anyone
who can speak for the board but if they
could be here uh yes representative I'm
just curious how often uh does the board
meet or is it just when a meeting is
called can can that happen uh relatively
they meet monthly
representative they meet every month
representative crota
so let's just say that
let's take so one one position might be
that they
that this would not fall under their
jurisdiction
and then another position might be that
they would accept jurisdiction for those
individuals that are certified through
this any program
but would not include but would not be a
certification
that I mean is there such a thing in
oplc
director
so um typically the way a board receives
jurisdiction is through a mandatory
certification or through a certification
a license or registration that's issued
so this um actually they would not have
jurisdiction if they were approving
National certification bodies they would
basically it would be saying
um
I think the way I would read it is
saying you know this generally Falls
within the scope
um except we're going to exempt from
license from the licensure requirement
these particular individuals
um so I think arguably one can make the
uh
um this would some this would be
something we'd have to talk about back
at the office but I think one could make
the argument that if somebody doesn't
meet this requirement is not required to
be licensed and is providing such
services that the veterinary board could
proceed
um with an unlicensed practice action
usually through the consumer protection
division of the Department of Justice
okay because my concern is
you know Chiropractic Chiropractic this
this
procedure is conducted on not only dogs
but it's also conducted on horses I mean
it's it's a real thing right and I would
hate to
um
I don't want to compare it to you know a
heart transplant because it's but at the
same time I feel some sort of
responsibility to
um at least have some some sort of guard
rails on the thing so that large animals
are which are a completely different
thing
than a dog and which is different than a
human at least there's some sort of
feeling you know there's this program
that you have to be certified so that
just not anybody who thinks they're a
chiropractor can go out to somebody's
farm and treat their animals that's all
I'm concerned about that
if I may respond representative so
that's so again oplc is not taking a
position and
um
but that's why I drafted the language to
require the board recognize a national
certification body it seemed like a
reasonable compromise because
um you know I think there could be a
legitimate concern that people would
just start providing this service and
have
um no not be qualified to do so
I have a question I mean I can see that
they might have concern that they're
approving certain National
certifications and there's a requirement
if you're going to practice legally you
have to have that certification but then
all of the other stuff that goes with
most licensing wouldn't be there I don't
know disciplining all that which I'm not
looking for but is there any anywhere
else any other uh thing in licensing
where something like this is done where
there's a requirement that a
practitioner gets some private
nationally recognized certification and
then that's it
that the the state doesn't do anything
further
yeah we we don't think there is I mean
it's very common for as a part of either
statute or rules for a licensed
individual to have a certification which
is the basis for the licensure
um but we're not familiar off the top of
our heads with basically a requirement
to have a voluntary certification
through a private organization to be
exempt from licensure
okay thank you uh representative short
thank you
um I I'm in favor of waiting until
um these two Alternatives can be
presented to the actual board members
and hear from them
if they have a preference one way or the
other whether what is the total
exemption or the The Proposal from
can we can we wait that long schedule
okay
uh
representative so I'm I'm not saying
that I want certification but I like to
have some sort of if there's a way that
oplc can examine that and then once we
have statute we can put that into
rulemaking that it would fall under the
consumer protection
right
okay good I mean that makes sense if
that can work
um
because I certainly don't want to set up
you know a whole licensing regimen for
the normal thing for animal Chiropractic
so
yeah if that can work that would be um
and a representative uh Kelly if you
could
contact people that you know that are
actually doing this
to get some idea of do they tend to be
certified by some national body do they
tend not to and what their view is maybe
either somebody could come in whenever
we reschedule this or you could bring
the information back
yeah and and maybe she could refer you
to somebody else or maybe you know
somebody to to get some information
what's going on here so we know what
we're
what we're messing with so
all right um anyone else out there want
thank you representative my name is
Simon Thompson I work with a firm Sheen
Finney Capital group and uh I'm here on
behalf of the new the New Hampshire
State Chiropractic Society
uh yesterday afternoon uh the president
of the New Hampshire State Chiropractic
Society Matt's wise sent the entire
board an email excuse me at the entire
comedian email which kind of outlines
where we're at and I think the the the
the the first message we want to deliver
is that we're not opposed to
chiropractors you know treating animals
um but the the original bill and the
sponsor's amendment
we were initially neutral but then
opposed to it the language that director
Courtney just presented is something
that I think we would again probably
move back to neutral what our concern is
and in that email that that Dr swice
sent yesterday is that
when you go to Chiropractic College it's
to learn how to treat humans okay and
one of the things that's important to
chiropractors when they get a new
patient who's you know I have to try to
read this word that's that are that are
have you know musculoskeletal complaints
and therefore a chiropractor could
perhaps address that when they come in
they still need to they're trained in
that college to to know what those red
flags are that is this is this a cancer
tumor that's causing this pain and
therefore we need to get you out of our
office into somebody who can handle that
so if we're just going to say that oh
yeah you can you can treat animals or
horses without any guardrails or
certification to identify the red flags
that they do not know about because they
were not trained to do that in their
college that's a concern for them
so I think if you get a chance to take a
look at it you'll see some pretty good
examples of of why we're concerned with
the original bill and the amendment and
why the language just got brought to
your attention from oplc we would
probably be neutral on
um and then the other thing I just want
to let people know is that our
association is the largest Association
of the chiropractors in New Hampshire
and we're estimating that maybe five
percent do this
um and and and so that is kind of where
we're at that you know I think I think
that the Avenue you guys are approaching
to maybe slow the train down and hear
from the veterinarian board and if we
can schedule another a subcommittee work
session I can have an actual
chiropractor who's more technically
knowledgeable than I am to come in and
kind of express our concerns uh that
would be great but I'm here today to say
that we were opposed to the amended
version of Representative Kelly's bill
but this language that director uh
Courtney just brought forward we could
be
neutral on
okay and I'm happy to answer any
questions any questions for him
all right thank you
anyone else who wants to speak on House
Bill 258.
any other discussion
here so I mean
I yeah I'm I'm in favor of um waiting
and scheduling another subcommittee
meeting as you say this isn't an early
Bill and so we have some time to wait to
representative yeah I was good do we
need a motion to just postpone to the
next subcommittee meeting or I don't
know but we can make one yes okay I
don't think so but okay then let's just
wait okay all right uh so we're I'm
gonna close the work session on House
Bill 258 and we're back at one o'clock
foreign
hey I'm going to open the subcommittee
work session and a house bill 409 and um
I think at the last
at the you know after the meeting last
time
um
we asked um director Courtney
um to you know propose an amendment to
deal with some concern she had and we
have that before us
and there were two issues one is
just having the license doesn't mean
there aren't problems that isn't
suspended or something like that so she
had it in good standing
and then there was kind of a technical
fix that the original bills had States
and that would have excluded DC and so
it's changed its jurisdiction
and so if you'd like to make you know
introduce yourself and and make any
comments you have on it hello my name is
Lauren Warner um I am general counsel
for the office of professional licensure
as well as oversee board council at oplc
so I am here on behalf of oplc as well
as I can answer questions regarding the
board stance because I was at the uh
their last Cosmo meeting
and what was your name again I'm sorry
and um so you're speaking for oplc and
the board so if you can
comment on on the amendment that uh that
director Courtney proposed would you
like to make a comment on it on behalf
of oplc or as the board why don't you do
one and then the other yes so so
essentially for oplc they aren't taking
a position on the bill but director
Courtney drafted this language to amend
some of the concerns that oplc had as
well as adding more clarity as you had
correctly stated
um essentially the prior version allowed
for anyone who maybe have had a
probation as a suspended license
um has a license but it's not
technically in good standing due to
discipline I could obtain licensure
automatically in New Hampshire by the
basis of just having a license so this
amendment would remove those concerns
and allow only those who are in good
standing
um in another jurisdiction to obtain
licensure via reciprocity one thing I to
talk about with director Courtney oh
well I'm sorry oh go on um just a little
bit earlier this morning was maybe
adding to it and defining what in good
standing
entails um Inwood standing is common
language to use but in some board rules
we could certainly address that there
Define what in good standing is I know
also the mental health
licensure they are looking for
conditional license in good standing and
we're looking also for endorsement to
Define
you know what Ingot standing really
meant how did does it mean you held a
license for a certain amount of years
and now you're qualified does it mean
there is no past pending or current
discipline because essentially someone
could be in current good standing but
had past discipline
um New Hampshire boards may want to look
at what happened in that past discipline
and would that cause a public safety
so I think that in good standings is
something that can be addressed in rules
yes and I think that we would I would
recommend that we do that okay
that's a good point representative
thank you um
I know this isn't your field but
are you aware of the recent case in
Florida where literally thousands of
nursing qualifications that were put
forward
were shown to be fake and there have
been I think 25 or 26 arrests involving
that
um
do you know if if New Hampshire would
have the capability of
um discovering something of that nature
in this field if that was the case
um so I can speak to nursing first
because I um and board Council for
nursing uh they are part so we've been
working with federal law authorities and
are given identifying names when they
confirm those who have possibly attended
schools that were actually
like a paid for graduate degree so we've
been giving regular lists for those that
are New Hampshire licensed nurses and
are then the board is reviewing those
and bringing in to them for show cause
or adjudications and determining had
they had other criteria and education
that could meet for
um Cosmo
similarly they could look into that if
there was perhaps information that came
out and similarly federal legal
authorities wanted to send that
information one benefit with nursing is
they have a compact so information can
be spread Nationwide among those compact
states there isn't a compact for
cosmetology
let's have questions and this is on
there representing basically oplc's
position
okay and then for the board for the
board they had previously submitted
written testimony at the full committee
session last week essentially there it
discusses
Health sanitary Infectious Disease
Control concerns just based on the
training that New Hampshire
cosmetologists are required to have to
be licensed that is a big part of their
training as well as it's one of the main
concerns the board sees from in
disciplinary actions as or as well as
inspections they're routinely if someone
fails an inspection I would say about 90
of the time it has to do with
poor sanitary consist condition
conditions instruments that are not
properly cleaned or sanitized of that
nature so they were concerned as to
would it potentially open up some states
just because of automatic licensure they
weren't required to meet the
substantially
you know subsimilar or more than
language that potentially they could
allow for those who have less training
in those areas could be licensed
um so that was one of their concerns as
well as generally what
Lindsay Courtney's sorry director
Courtney's Amendment addresses
having anyone who could be licensed a
suspended license in another state could
be like have an active license in New
Hampshire is someone regularly have poor
inspection reports and is still
maintained licensure whereas in New
Hampshire they would have taken action
on that license based on that
disciplinary action they wouldn't
necessarily be allowed to as the
original language were to go forward
foreign
so what's somebody let's say they go
from one state to the other they come
here and we give them a license
once they get that license it's a New
Hampshire license so they have to follow
the New Hampshire rules correct yes but
their concern is essentially coming in
so they wouldn't necessarily have to
follow New Hampshire rules for initial
licensure because it would be
reciprocity so they wouldn't have to
meet the same training
um eventually at renewal time they would
have to follow those it was just more of
a concern regarding what could
potentially happen in those first two
years if someone doesn't have the same
training qualifications in some of those
areas where they see significant
problems
so if somebody were to hire them let's
say
and those individuals were not following
the hygiene rules that the
shop owner has or the manager of the
established they would have the right to
request that the proper
hygiene
is followed correct right these people
okay so I'm just trying to figure out
how because I think that
getting to
it's because it's it's such a
diverse
thing yes
and
it's wide and shallow
you know what I mean as opposed to
narrow and deep
and when something is wide and shallow
it's hard to sort of like maneuver your
way through these things
so my thought is that
we
um my thing my thinking is that we
accept a presented I mean a director
Courtney's Amendment
we amend 409 to say that
we pass 409 as amended with that rule
and then we put this the good standing
definition in rules
and then
um there has to be some way that the
board can communicate to their business
owners
that you know if they're concerned about
this they're going to have to
enforce that kind of practice in their
own business yes you know what I mean
yes somebody has to hold the ball and
you know
and I it's I really don't think that you
know we're gonna have
cosmetologists lining up at the border
to become a New Hampshire
licensed owner but at the same time I
understand their concerns but I'm trying
to figure out how we can do this in a
way that doesn't
you know cause a big tangle
and using the current
protocols that we have in place that to
me is the cleanest way of getting to
where
we we
this is the cleanest way to get TS is
what I'm trying to figure out yes
because I'm I think this is serious
but I think that if we notify the boards
that this is I mean the board that this
is going to happen and we know I mean
the shop owners are part of that yes
right yes and it's up to them because
they own those businesses they don't
they don't have to hire these people if
they don't want to yes and they'll be
the ones susceptible to coming before
the board for because essentially the
inspection would be done on their shop
so if those who worked for them right
were causing those violations the shop
owner also has to answer for them
adjudication that's right so I think
that's the best way to to do it
and I would also know
creating in good standing just generally
thinking from an oplc point of view and
having rules that would define no no
past pending or current discipline if
someone of that had a license with no
discipline on it the likelihood that
they would then come to New Hampshire
and
engage in discipline would I think be
far less than someone who potentially
has a number of failed inspections and
had past discipline on their license
yes just with clarification even if the
statute passes until the rules pass the
statute doesn't
we have to Define good standing and
rules right before we launch this off I
think for a lot of our statutes have in
good standing and rules they don't
necessarily describe what it is it can
be used I think it would be best for the
board to Define it in rules to make it
clear that these are the factors they're
looking at to put the like those
potential licensees on notice
okay that's great thanks thank you
anybody uh representative
um as a member
until recently of gel Carr I agree with
the statement that wouldn't necessarily
be in rules it would have to come back
to the board I'll State further that I
have been opposed to
changing the language from substantially
equivalent for exactly the reason as I
stated in Florida I'm not ready to
um trust the investigative powers of
some of our other states in the union
to state that this person is qualified
and whatever they say if they can fake
nursing certificates for heaven's sakes
they certainly could fake cosmetology
certification but wouldn't that be a
problem with people that are
you know licensed in New Hampshire maybe
less of one because if they took classes
locally but
um you know if they came from a state
that had similar requirements they which
we would accept
aren't we open to the same issue and
representative Barry you had a question
hey bear sorry
thank you
um I am in support of this bill and I
think I was just curious at the last
hearing I had asked a question and I'm
not sure whether I had asked it of the
sponsor or I had asked it of olpc but I
was curious how many new applications
from out of state that you guys were
getting did you know that answer do you
know that answer or did we get that
answer I don't know if you got that
answer I can check with director
Courtney and forcing off the top of my
head I do not but I can certainly get
that answer and email it on to you all
follow on
thank you I just am curious how many
people that we would be helping
bypassing this bill on an average and
yes certainly I didn't get that
information
any other questions or comments
and I just note the cosmo board is
meeting this um upcoming Monday so I'll
be bringing um director Courtney's
amendment to them and so they can review
any discussion or
would you like to make a motion
yes I'd like to um
pass the amendment to a to amend 409
with the language that we provided for
that was provided for by oplc
second right here
so any
um
actually I guess I hadn't seen the
actual Amendment
um and it does delete the
um
licensing requirements being
substantially equivalent
so
um I'm sorry I'm I object to that so
I'll be voting no okay
any other discussion
if not uh representative Grotto
yes representative short
no representative a bearer yes and the
chair votes yes
okay thank you
um with that I will close the
subcommittee work session on House Bill